Hi. So today I wanted to talk about the pros,
the cons about nursing in the UK
versus nursing here in the United States.
Let's get into it.
Yeah. So some of the pros
from nurses working in the United Kingdom.
Won free healthcare.
They entitled to free health care.
Nurses working in the UK benefit from free health care
for themselves and their families,
which means
they don't have to worry about medical expenses.
Number one. Number 2,
the patient scheme.
Okay, this is
working in the UK.
Have access to patient scheme,
which provides financial security in their retirement.
Number 3. Work life balance.
The National Health Service
NHS in the UK is.
Has strict shoes around working hours and rest periods,
which means nurses can expect a good work life balance.
Don't we all need that employment Protection already?
Nurses in the UK have strong employment Protection laws,
which means they are less likely to be
unfairly dismissed or discriminated against.
That's a plus.
It's not happening here.
Standardized training and education. Okay.
The nursing profession in the UK is heavily regulated,
which means nurses
expect a high standard of training and education.
Alrighty. The cons for nurses in the UK.
Lower salaries.
Hmm. Okay. And this is in the UK
generally unless.
Than their counterparts here in the United States.
All right. Which can make it harder to make ends meet.
More over time for you.
Work life balance 0.
Limited career progression.
The nursing profession in the UK Is high.
How can I put it?
It's limited,
I would say,
which means there may be limited opportunities
for career progression.
Okay, stop. Shortages.
The NHS in the UK has been struggling, okay,
with stuff shortages for some time,
which can lead to high workloads,
increased tracefulnesses,
which we all know is happening,
cause, you know,
they're getting nurses from all over now,
just like in the United States.
And then there's also limited autonomy
for nurses in the UK, which.
Which means, you know,
nurses in the UK have less autonomy in their practice
than I see in the United States,
as their care system in the UK is more centralized.
You know, climates,
okay, depending on one's preference.
The UK's weather can be downside for some people,
especially for some of us from the tropical,
especially those who are,
you know, we are used to live in,
you know, in, in.
In a warmer climate.
Some of the pros for nurses in the US, okay,
higher salaries.
Nurses in the US generally,
and higher salaries than those in the UK,
which can provide financial security.
Okay. Greater career opportunities.
The US healthcare system is more diverse than the UK,
okay? Which means that there are more
opportunities for career progression,
specialization.
There's a lot that you can do with your degree
here in the United States.
And then autonomy in practice.
I love that, okay,
about the system here.
Nurses in the US
may have greater autonomy in their practice.
You know, than those in the UK.
As a healthcare system in the US is more decentralized,
so we love that. About that.
More resources as well.
The US healthcare system is generally better funded
than that one in the UK,
which means
there may be more resources available for nurses.
All right, and then we're going to talk about climate.
Depending on launch preferences,
the US climate can be
Pro for some people,
especially those that enjoy,
you know, warm up.
Depending on why you land anyways,
because some,
some winters
and some parts of the US are also aggressive.
Yeah, so let's talk about the cones.
My baby's awake now. I gotta go.
The cones. For the US healthcare costs.
Nurses working in the US
may have to pay for their health care,
which can be expensive.
Of course, there's insurance,
so it is what it is,
but it is expensive.
And then work life balance.
Nurses here in the United States
have poor work life balance.
Yeah. Compared to our friends in the UA.
In the UK, as often
fewer regulations around working hours and rest periods,
which is true.
Employment Protection.
Nurses in the US may have less employment Protection
than those in the UK.
You know, standardized on training and education.
And nursing profession in the US
is less regulated than that in the UK.
Which means that there may be a greater variation
in the quality of training and education available.
Patient load.
They'll say Necessary
and maybe respond
for a higher patient load than those in the UK,
which can lead to increased trace and burnout. So
choose your. Choose your heart.
I gotta call my babies awake. Love you.